but I've known so many talented people
who um just couldn't get that break just
couldn't get that that one thing
I have a quote here for you great
Passion not pedigree will win in the end
and this is from none other than Jon Bon
Jovi oh one of my favorites I might have
had a few of his posters on my wall so
that's awesome
um yeah I I love that uh you know I feel
like uh well Us in the movie industry we
love an Underdog Story right
um but I feel like it's certainly where
I come from like you know I'm not one of
these people that has like a real chip
on their shoulder about uh the nepo
babies or anything like that you know I
feel like everybody's everybody's got a
path into this business and uh it is
what it is but that is the exact reason
I love Bon Jovi is because
um the idea that a poor kid from Bossier
City Louisiana can you know move out to
LA and get to do what I get to do is
definitely an Underdog Story to me
um and I love the idea of
you know passion and uh uh discipline
and doing all the things that you need
to do to be good at this job and to get
this job will get you there it also
takes a very very healthy amount of luck
um because I I wish that it was just
about how much you work or how much you
put into it it's not really you know I I
think it's
um somebody said something about you
know the the more prepared you are the
luckier you get that's absolutely true
but I've known so many talented people
who um just couldn't get that break just
couldn't get that that one thing that
legitimized them in the eyes of somebody
else and then that person gives you a
job and then you know then you're
legitimatized in the eyes of three other
people or five other people and it just
your circle keeps expanding until you
are considered Real by enough people
that you work right
um
when I was 17 I was in uh Shreveport
Louisiana Bossier City Louisiana and uh
I would drive to Dallas three hours to
audition for stuff my mom would drive me
um so
I was 15 and she drove me to Dallas and
I auditioned for this thing and the guy
liked me
and called me back so I drove back to
Louisiana
two days later I drive back to Dallas we
do this call back
I have no idea what this thing is none
you know it's like I'm in the Callback
I'm matched with somebody who I assumed
that she had the part and so we're
supposed to be drowning or something and
we're screaming and yelling and anyways
and we go back you know we're back in
the hotel or whatever and um they my
agent calls and says we can't send that
to NBC like we need you to do it again
and I'm like either they said we felt
you were matching the energy off of the
girl you were playing against but she
wasn't doing a good job so you didn't do
a good job and I'm like oh wait I'm the
lead guy I'm the guy that you're
thinking about not her like okay sure so
I did another audition and I booked this
movie where they flew me and my mom to
Australia
and I was the only actor who was
actually under 18. I was the only actor
who is not from Los Angeles everyone
else in the show was on it was on a
major TV show on the network
I have no idea why I booked that job I
have no idea why the director went to
any lengths at all to get
um a 16 year old kid from Bossier City
Louisiana in a movie where I played
opposite
Vinnie from Blossom you know and uh this
actress from empty nest and you know all
of these people that were on TV at the
time it's such an enormous risk to take
somebody who has never done this before
and then put them in scenes with
professionals like uh it's hard it's a
that's a big risk I don't know why they
did that but they did and because of
that I got that Western it's the only
reason I got the Western is because I
had more work experience than the other
guys they were looking at that's it so
then I had two movies and then like
that's how I was able to you know step
in in front of a lot of talented great
young actors who didn't quite have their
sag guard who didn't quite have you know
a body of work behind them
um and so that's I don't know why that
happened I'm thankful for it every day I
never forget that that's the whole
reason that I'm probably still doing
this because if I hadn't have gotten
that chance in Dallas when I was still
in high school I probably would have
taken a different path of like well I'll
go to college you know maybe I'll study
theater and college and then I'll be 23
24 by the time I get out and then I
don't have
a union card or a you know a resume or
anything like that but I've done Hamlet
on the college stage you know what I
mean uh anyways I I just know so many
talented people that have not gotten
that lotto ticket you know who uh just
struggled and struggled just to get into
the Union when they got out here and uh
but I do think I think it's a gift and
I'm thankful for it and so I work hard
and I I don't complain too much about
the things that I have to do because I
do feel like that luck is such a big
part of it
and I see that in the comments that we
we get about nepo babies and I had to
like look that up because that wasn't a
term that I knew for a long time but and
and having grown up around a lot of
wealth even though I grew up poor as
well that route isn't always that easy
there's different pressures
yeah lots of different things I mean
it's difficult to really get on the you
know what I'm not gonna die on that Hill
you know what I mean but I mean come on
man you know it's like everybody's dealt
their hand you know it's like uh
the whatever everybody's dealt a hand I
don't I like a lot of those actors that
are getting criticized right now because
of being able to step in because of
their parents or whatever there's some
really talented people that I go and
watch their movies because I like them
you know so I'm not mad about it do what
they want just don't act like it's not a
thing it's really the only thing I think
people want people just want an
acknowledgment of like just like guys
how lucky I am to have gotten that job
you know
when nobody knew me nobody had a reason
to give it to me just a little
um humble
-ness about the the situation that
sometimes you get the Aces and sometimes
you don't and if you get the aces you
better be thankful for it sure I like
what you said just just try to
acknowledge that that it does exist but
I also see in the comments that people
uh are upset over not having enough
money to make a film or have the money
to go to film school right but I think
it can still you can still do something
yeah it's going to be a tougher Road and
you can still get your side card working
extra work yeah and they feed you and
you get paid a small amount so things
can happen even if you you know you can
go to Community College for a couple
years and then try to transfer I mean
yeah I think absolutely and I will say
this I think the biggest Cop Out is
saying I don't have enough money to make
a movie and I don't have enough money to
film school because every town in every
city in every state in this country
there is some nerd who's got a little
camera who wants to make his movie and
is looking for people to do it for free
like just come and help me make this
movie and um you can be that nerd you
know if you can afford to buy a camera
but guess what if you have a phone
you've got a cam right the idea that you
can't make a movie unless it's your Opus
is ridiculous and I do feel like a lot
of people have that idea of like I'm not
going to compromise my vision it's 2001
it's gonna cost eight billion dollars
you know I'm like great fantastic but
you so save it but you can still be
working you can still be honing your
craft you can work you know as a as a
grip as a gaffer as a sound person on on
shorts and in features I've done
features where I'm so desperate to find
a body you know that I'm letting people
who have never done this be the first
assistant camera person they can stand
right next to the guy who does this for
a living and learn right and usually get
paid something like there's so many
different ways in order to work and um
even in the acting field which is
incredibly competitive but like you know
I know so many young people who get out
here and they go on Backstage they look
for the short films and every third one
is a nightmare and then the other two
are great you know it's like going out
putting yourself out there any other
city in the country has theater that you
can do all over the place I think
theater is freaking fantastic and I mean
La is a very strange town for theater
there are great theaters here they're
just few and far between because there's
a struggle between the equity and the
non-equity blah blah blah I've done
great theater in L.A uh if not I've done
great I I I've done fine but I've worked
with great theaters in the LA area and
it's like you know what you go and do
that and then you meet the other actors
and then you have a tribe then you have
a group and maybe they have agents but
maybe they have other projects it's like
the idea that oh I can't but you know uh
Ron Howard's daughter can it's totally
unfair it's like well there's a lot of
Disconnect between that and that you
know what I mean
I don't know I have a lot to say about
it I guess yeah no I I see that come up
a lot for people and and having grown up
you know with a single mom and and not
have money for college I was in a
similar boat uh so I I can understand
them being frustrated but at the same
time we're in a different era where yes
you can make something very easily you
can edit yourself that wasn't available
when I was looking through the Sears
catalog and I saw that movie camera that
I wanted to get right right I mean
that's another thing about the the luck
aspect of it being such an important
thing is that the timing of my career
you know it couldn't have happened any
time before you know like if I had
graduated in 85 instead of 95
um then I wouldn't have had the
opportunities to make short films and
stuff that of equality you know like the
the first one two the first three films
that I made weren't even in HD they were
you know DV cam but that was
the highest Tech that you could get at
the time for a price and the
the platforms the the networks and
whatnot we're okay with it right it was
a very tiny window between film and HD
and like right in here are these little
DV cameras and that was what I could
afford to do that's how I figured out
how to raise money for that and make
that but here or here and like that
doesn't fall for me the way that it did
um
so yeah it's it's a thing luck and
timing are so much a part of it uh all
you can do is just be prepared you know
to take the ball when you get the
opportunity to catch it